[Musica]
Grazie di questa presentazione ma vi
devo dire che essere Esso Sono
emozionato perché sono davanti a mille
persone mille persone sono più o meno i
cittadini del mio comune quindi questa
sera è interessantissimo è come parlare
a tutti i miei cittadini
contemporaneamente
vi devo dire che forse è inusuale che un
sindaco sia su un palco di un the Dexter
però vi devo dire anche che non so
quanti lo sapete Ma in Italia i comuni
sono circa 8.000 di questi 8.000 5.000
sono piccoli comuni e vi assicuro che
impegnarsi in azioni concrete con i
cittadini è meraviglioso e fare il
sindaco è meraviglioso e spero di farvi
intuire perché andiamo all'oggetto della
serata perché la World Major Foundation
di Londra ha deciso di premiare con il
community e World un sindaco di un
piccolo comune
San Bellino in provincia di Rovigo
Vorrei prendermi il merito di questo
risultato ma non lo posso fare è
risultato di relazioni con i cittadini
con gli amministratori con i dipendenti
che ho coinvolto in una visione non
legata all'oggi Ma già al Domani al
dopodomani e con un'idea che voleva
creare delle azioni amministrative in
cui i cittadini diventassero con
protagonisti e corresponsabili del bene
comune
Anzi ho pensato che il benessere civico
aumenta cresce nella misura in cui il
cittadino viene responsabilizzato e
responsabilizzandolo si occupa di una
cosa che si chiama comunità tutti noi
sappiamo che cos'è una comunità è fatta
di beni materiali ma anche di beni
materiali
il l'aiuto reciproco e fare azioni verso
la cosa pubblica impegnarsi in azioni e
progettazione di attività pubbliche cioè
il cittadino ha un potere
ma deve essere consapevole e deve e
dobbiamo anche dare a lui gli strumenti
anche nuovi per poterlo esercitare
nel 2014 tutto inizia decido di
candidarmi a sindaco con uno slogan
perché volevo fare il sindaco in un modo
diverso e lo slogan era il tempo della
delega è finito ho scelto una squadra di
giovani con competenza diversificate che
ingegnere chi avvocato chi medico chi
imprenditore che gli studenti
universitari e con loro Ho immaginato Il
comune come un laboratorio del futuro in
cui le azioni
progettuali e le azioni amministrative
dovevano essere tarate anche per poter
essere applicate nei quartieri e nelle
periferie della città
in cui necessariamente il cittadino
doveva esserne parte progettuale interna
quindi una sorta di forzatura
apparentemente perché in ambito pubblico
di solito si stanziano le risorse e si
fanno i progetti
nella
visione che abbiamo avuto in realtà
l'opera pubblica è sì fondamentale ma è
molto più importante il percorso
educativo e formativo del cittadino
all'interno di questa
percorso in cui lui diventa
attore protagonista e può essere
elemento fondamentale anche nella
progettazione
l'obiettivo che abbiamo messo in gioco
Era proprio quello di immaginare che
nell'ambito pubblico di solito non si
ragiona per proclami Ma si ragiona per
atti e abbiamo cercato un modo per
trasformare
rispettando la legge il semafori della
pubblica amministrazione rotonde
provo a raccontarvi qualche esempio
siamo nei due anni della pandemia che
tutti abbiamo conosciuto due anni
tremendi in cui
il le persone si trovavano in una
situazione tutti noi ci troviamo in una
situazione di prostrazione importante i
pensieri non riuscivano ad essere ricchi
di ottimismo dovevamo trovare un modo
per ridare energia speranza ad una
comunità
e per fare questo guardando sempre le
immagini televisive le persone si
sentivano oppresse da quell'orrore e
anche il linguaggio dire
distanziamento sociale piuttosto che
dire distanza di sicurezza il linguaggio
è un macigno sulle reazioni e noi
volevamo lavorare sulle relazioni l'idea
ci è venuta da un appello di un
florovivaista i floresti in Italia sono
27.000 un florovivaista non poteva in
quel periodo del lockdown vendere i
propri prodotti e si è trovato di fronte
ad a fare un appello sia sui giornali
che sui social in cui diceva devo
chiudere perché non riesco più ad andare
avanti allora ci venne un'idea come fare
ad aiutare i cittadini a restare a casa
e contemporaneamente aiutare un
imprenditore che aveva fatto questo
appello era un mio studente lo
chiamargli di sì spiegami un attimo fa
in due settimane buttare tutto al macero
quindi lo Chiamai gli dissi io ti
comprerei tutto quello che tu hai a un
prezzo chiaramente concordato e
simbolico perché voglio donarlo ai
cittadini e questo abbiamo fatto arrivò
con un camion pieno di bellezza di fiori
di ortaggi e i volontari e le volontarie
realizzarono quella che si chiama la
cassetta delle coltivazioni l'abbiamo
chiamata in questo modo cioè abbiamo
donato ad ogni una delle 400 famiglie
del mio comune una cassetta con una
lettera firmata al mio nome in cui c'era
scritto
metti questi fiori o sul tuo terrazzo
sul tuo balcone nel tuo giardino perché
facendo questo In realtà rendi bello il
tuo paese e facendo questo In realtà
coltivi buoni pensieri Coltiva la terra
per coltivare i buoni pensieri li dà un
senso così al tempo che sei costretto a
vivere a domicilio fu un quantitativo di
ricchezza di colori all'interno nostra
comunità che l'esempio diventò così
interessante che fu preso in esame da
altri comuni il comune di Padova 200
mila abitanti poi i giornali nazionali
lo ripresero e l'idea divenne virale
quell'imprenditore decise dopo
quell'esperienza comunitaria di non
licenziare nessuno dei suoi dipendenti
questo vale anche in progettazioni che
possono essere legate ai lavori pubblici
sportive o anche in ambito legato
all'ambiente mai come oggi noi sentiamo
parlare di cambiamenti climatici ne
siamo tutti purtroppo coinvolti e anche
qui una domanda che che mi è nata perché
in realtà mi chiamano il sindaco degli
alberi
irridendomi ma io devo dirvi che ne sono
felice e ho deciso di provare a trovare
un modo ponendomi una domanda che era
questa Come può un piccolo comune fare
qualcosa per creare
meccanismi di mitigazione e adattamento
ai cambiamenti climatici da solo può
fare molto poco ma se si coinvolgono i
cittadini del proprio comune quelli di
altri comuni questo si può fare e quindi
decidemmo di realizzare un progetto che
si chiama ridiamo il sorriso la Pianura
Padana una forestazione in proprietà
privata
questo progetto in realtà è un progetto
Open perché può essere applicato a tutto
il nord Italia tutta la nostra pianura e
andai anche qui a Bologna alla sede
della regione Emilia Romagna incontrai
Un assessore che spiegare il progetto e
ne rimase colpito perché in realtà
all'inizio decidemmo in tre province e
10 comuni di metterci insieme comuni
appartenenti anche a indicazioni
politiche diverse perché non volevamo
che fosse una bandiera del terminare il
valore di quel progetto e abbiamo deciso
di donare ai cittadini di questi dieci
comuni tra Rovigo Padova e Vicenza
piante da per piantare nella propria
proprietà privata né donammo 20.000
Queste piante in realtà andando nelle
proprietà private Hanno praticamente
annullato i costi futuri dell'ente
pubblico per la manutenzione il progetto
funziona la regione Veneto decide di
farlo proprio in carica il proprio
vivaio regionale di produrre 70.000
piante e donarle i cittadini in 40
giorni hanno richiesto quelle 70 mila
piante altre 70.000 L'anno successivo e
anche lì sono andate immediatamente
richieste da parte dei cittadini
350 comuni coinvolti e questo progetto
che risulta essere una sorta di
forestazione
condivisa di pianura funziona
in realtà la cosa molto bella è che
l'aria non si ferma ai confini delle
proprietà private e il vantaggio è per
tutta la comunità Inoltre se cambiasse
l'amministrazione e Risulti essere
un'amministrazione non sensibile al
verde automaticamente non può incidere e
venire a tagliare gli alberi che
qualcuno può aver piantato nella propria
proprietà privata quindi questo progetto
funziona ve ne voglio presentare un
altro a cui tengo molto voglio
realizzare un comune senza barriere
architettoniche per fare questo In
realtà qualche anno fa mi serviva la
realizzazione di un piano si chiama peba
tecnicamente piano per eliminazione
delle barriere architettoniche ma
l'obiettivo è quello di fare in modo che
i luoghi siano accessibili e questo è
bellissimo pensate a 8.000 comuni
Pensate se tutti adottassero un piano
vuol dire che ogni azione che viene
fatta all'interno di questo comune
permette a ciascuno di noi di accedere
ovunque
perché questo piano in realtà nel
momento in cui volevo farlo fu il primo
nella provincia di Rovigo e non sapevo a
chi chiedere a un certo punto decidi di
chiamare il comitato paralimpico gli
chiese avete qualcuno e loro mi dissero
Sì ma abbiamo un architetto che ha già
fatto esperienza e venne a trovarmi in
comune in realtà quando arrivò vi
assicuro io vidi la sua auto che mi
piaceva moltissimo però un sindaco a
volte pensa ai soldi e automaticamente
al bilancio è la prima cosa che è venuto
in mente è stato Chissà che parcella mi
presenterà
in realtà succede Questo apre la porta
della sua auto la prima cosa che scende
da quell'auto e la sua carrozzina e con
quella carrozzina arrivo nel mio comune
lo accolsi dovete accoglierlo al piano
terra perché non avevo modo di farlo
arrivare ai piani superiori al mio
ufficio mi mancava un ascensore
lui mi fece quel piano me lo fece anche
per un prezzo simbolico quando gli
raccontava un po' le nostre idee la
nostra visione però quell'ascensore
Dovevo farla e doveva essere la prima
cosa da fare togliere le barriere nella
casa di vetro nella casa di tutti che è
il municipio E allora decisi di
scegliere una strada avevo i soldi per
realizzare quell'ascensore li avevo ma
ho deciso di richiedere la regione un
terzo di quei soldi un terzo l'ha messo
comune e un terzo doveva arrivare dai
cittadini che comprendevano il valore di
quel percorso che stavamo iniziando
arrivarono donazioni dalle famiglie
dalle associazioni dal centro anziani
arrivò anche una donazione da un signore
della provincia di Bologna un
imprenditore che mi fece una donazione
cospicua tanto che io a un certo punto
decisi di venire a trovarlo perché
volevo capire il motivo perché aveva
deciso di Donare denaro al mio piccolo
comune
Andai da lui
e parlamo e mi raccontò che nel in una
fase della sua vita dovete spingere la
carrozzina con sua moglie e si accorse
della difficoltà di barriere cosa voleva
dire avere delle barriere sul territorio
e a un certo punto quando ci lasciamo mi
disse andate avanti vedo che le cose le
fate
Quindi quando in realtà
si inserisce
necessariamente Il Cittadino all'interno
di progetti di valore funziona
abbiamo fatto
[Applauso]
abbiamo fatto la stessa cosa per cercare
un modo per coinvolgere i cittadini in
un referendum propositivo abbiamo deciso
di cambiare e di aggiungere delle vie
all'interno del comune però abbiamo
detto facciamo un referendum in cui
tutti possono votare dai bambini e gli
adulti Perché lo scopo fondamentale era
che ognuno in una lista di personaggi
potesse comprenderne il valore e poi
essere o partecipe e corresponsabile del
nuovo assetto della toponomastica e del
nuovo assetto del territorio Facciamo
questo e fu una cosa interessantissima
perché tutti diventarono consapevoli di
ogni via e dei suoi nomi in più vi devo
dire che nel momento in cui si mette
insieme un progetto
condiviso e si trovano occasioni di
incontro tra le persone che ragionano su
quel progetto condiviso si alimenta e si
sviluppa la ri relazionale che è il
grande patrimonio immateriale che deve
essere sviluppato ed è presente nelle
nostre comunità è come è generativa è
come il lievito in una buona torta
è in qualche modo la capacità di poter
trasformare una società un comune una
comunità
da sempre più virtuale ha sempre più
reale ed è fondamentale perché questo
cambia il rapporto cambia le dinamiche
quindi un'idea condivisa
competenze in relazione tra loro ognuno
deve sapere il valore dell'altro ognuno
deve essere deve avere chiaro il suo
apporto per raggiungere l'obiettivo
comune e condiviso funziona funziona
poi mi devo dire che c'è anche chi non
vuole farsi coinvolgere Anzi arriva e
vuole
in qualche modo trasmetterti tutti i
suoi problemi e lamentele e quindi Qui
bisogna a volte agire con dei correttivi
a volte con dei correttivi creativi ve
ne racconto uno ne abbiamo applicati
vari uno di questi è
fatto in questo modo quando arriva una
persona agitata che vuole incontrarmi
all'interno del Municipio i dipendenti
mi avvertono
poi lo fanno salire e lo fanno
accomodare a delle sedie che ho
posizionato proprio davanti alla porta e
sulla porta ho messo questo cartello
mentre Attendi per entrare con un
problema pensa a possibili soluzioni
io attendo qualche minuto e lui nel
frattempo con il desiderio di entrare
continua a guardare quella porta e a
volte guardando quella porta inizia a
lavorare in qualche modo in un suo
dialogo interiore e quel dialogo
interiore lo porta anche a prendere
delle decisioni e a un certo punto mi
capita di aprire quella porta e lui
quando entra mi dice Sindaco io ho
questo problema Però avrei pensato che
si potrebbe con questa soluzione
e quindi ti accorgi
ti accorgi che a volte devi in qualche
modo solo dare valore e visibilità al
suo alla sua scelta e altre volte invece
ricercare da altre realtà perché per
aiutarlo per stimolarlo d'altra realtà
virtuose e difatti Io dico sempre che è
vietato non copiare le cose che
funzionano vanno copiate se possibile
migliorate Ecco e questo In realtà
in anni ho io ho visto che la gente
passo dopo passo inizia a cambiare
inizia a pensare che la propria
proprietà privata non si ferma al
proprio cancello di casa e questo è
qualcosa di straordinario ed è il mantra
su cui come amministrazione io ho
scommesso
questo approccio inclusivo in realtà
Rende
ogni cittadino un primo cittadino
ed è straordinario perché si bambini dai
bambini agli adulti ed è
emozionante quando ti accorgi che questa
dinamica prende forma ecco per
concludere vorrei dirvi che
c'è posto per tutti Nessuno escluso in
un progetto come questo
e mi auguro che in noi ci sia la
speranza in qualche modo di ritagliarsi
un po' di motivazione del tempo e dello
spazio per poter agire rispetto ai beni
comuni perché dalla qualità dei luoghi
comuni dipende la qualità della vita di
ciascuno di noi vi ringrazio Buona
serata e buona continuazione
[Musica]
[Applauso]